european union and eurozone obviously
doesn't want to lose this battle because
it might put into question the existence
of euro hi I'm Anthony and as a director
of economic research for the reason
foundation in pair of threes and TV I'm
sitting with mr. Murat you like he is
the Dean of the business school at thk
University in Ankara Turkey he and I
worked over the past year on turkish
u.s. trade issues mr. you like thank you
for joining us the first thing I want to
talk about is what's big in the news
right now is Greece how bad really is
the the Greek debt problem right now
it's pretty bad in terms of the debt
outlook as well as the economic outlook
in general the macroeconomic outlook
their economies let's say roughly around
three hundred billion dollars and there
that is about 450 do you think that the
privatization measures that are being in
put in place will be an effective part
of the fiscal plan well it is one of the
prime things what they are trying to do
is they are trying to reduce the
expenditures and privatization is one
main area where they want to do it
unfortunately Greece is defect or they
are in default the Greek parliament has
voted for his new measures and along
with it the German acceptance came the
German bondholders mostly the insurance
companies will also take you know some
kind of a haircut it's technically not a
haircut but you know they will bear part
of the burden at the order of a few
billion euros do you think that this
will be enough or is this just pushing
the matter maybe a year year and a half
down the road where crease will
eventually have to i'm pretty sure that
will happen i think we will have
recurrence of these things in the next
year and a half of course IMF is part of
the story as well and IMF 12 billion
tranche is now officially going to be
released because of this measures that
was watered by the parliament but when
the next tranche comes there again will
be similar situations and there the
Greek government will have to be
assessed on the basis of the past
implementation performance so what do
all these troubles for Greece in
particular mean broadly speaking for the
eurozone European Union and eurozone
obviously doesn't want to lose this
battle
because again if it loses this battle
then there will be the other battles in
in success in sequence which might put
into question the existence of Europe
let's talk about another country now
that's right next to grace as a little
bit of a stronger economy your own
country turkey turkey is the 15th 17th
largest economy in the world right now
and it's seeking to be in the top 10 by
20 23 what is turkey need to do to get
into the top 10 a lot of things but
basically turkey has a huge potential
that that has been untapped so far our
infrastructure physical and human we
have to develop it a country which wants
to become number 10 has to be able to
produce not consume technology and ideas
so far Frank the turkey looks more like
a consumer a good consumer of technology
whereas we need to start producing there
been some reports about recently talking
about the ease of doing business in
Turkey and that this is somewhat of a
challenge this is something that needs
to be overcome to be friendly and
precise the government has to reinvent
it tastes to be efficient which it is
not unfortunately so in those areas when
you look at Turkey it's really it ranks
very low in many of those indices by
different institutions are you
optimistic that turkey will be able to
get to the top 10 by 20 23 well what I
think is that naturally things go that
way if not number 10 these are very
symbolic you become number 15 again in a
growing economy which is where we are
right now let's start class about the
United States this is the debt ceiling
is big in the news here but you taught
economics development economics at
Georgetown you're familiar at the
American economy and you also do a lot
of business consulting in Europe so from
your outside perspective what does the
United States need to do to get its
fiscal house in order and preserve its
good credit rating to two ways one is to
text people more which will be
politically very difficult in this
country the other is basically you grow
yourself out of the situation you
brought all the talents to this country
they worked hard together with the
American talent obviously with a growing
economy so a growing economy
sustained let's say force of consumption
and production and vying for you know
increased revenue earning demand those
are the things that draw the American
economy so we can either Institute a
massive increase in taxes or we can
change our public policy to encourage
town to come from abroad and encourage
and incentivize domestic production
exactly that's the only way out thank
you so much for that Morales but a great
conversation thank you for being here
thank you for having me here for reason
TV I'm Anthony randazza